okay um steve urkel is just so iconic
um and he had that very famous
catchphrase
did i do that
that's exactly what he said not exactly
how he said it but that's exactly what
people try to say is smooth now
i mean first of all nerds became the hot
ones ironically so that worked out well
and you did grow up so handsome so
win-win
lush blush blush okay
absolutely dessert desserts dessert all
right so we want to play a game with you
and it's something called
did i do that
okay here's how it works i'm going to
read some scenarios and if you did it
you got to tell us the story and if you
didn't do it or you don't want to admit
that you did it you can say
did i do that and i guess we'll never
know
okay
and our audience gets to do this with us
all right
so
you have your polls in front of you and
if you think we did it you raise the
green side and if you don't think we did
it you raise the red side all right
jaleel we're gonna take turns asking the
questions to each other are you ready
let's go okay you go all right here we
go here we go
did you ever ding a car just a little
bit but you didn't tell anybody
drew
can you drive
okay i've done it
but in all fairness the last time i did
it i left a note and the person never
called me
okay
okay all right um so
okay my turn did you ever see someone at
a party and run the other way
[Laughter]
oh
you know what
yes
[Laughter]
yes even even worse
the first girl i ever made out with in
high school
i s i saw her at the school basketball
game the next week
and i hadn't called her
and so i just bolted out of the gym
[Laughter]
it happens you know we're all learning
in life how to handle situations okay
christy i'm sorry i'm sorry christy
christina he's sorry
i love that
all right
okay hold on i gotta get something good
for you now oh okay well
let's get down and dirty have you ever
flipped off a stranger
um 100
i uh give the bird a little too often
it feels good
there's nothing like it
[Applause]
okay did you ever act like urkel to
impress a girl
oh you know what you know what
no
no it's honest i i i it was one thing
that i just couldn't stand
when i was especially in my late teens
my in my college years if a girl that i
liked asked me to do the character
uh it was just like deflating because it
let me know she really wasn't checking
for me at all as a matter of fact i have
a really funny story i'll share it
really quickly i remember one time i was
checking out this girl and i was like oh
my gosh i just i just i gotta know her
and she was like um
she came up to me and i was just like i
thought it was the magnetism and she
came up to me and she said uh she said
um can i have a picture and i was like
and i said okay i'll tell you what
i'll give you my phone number
i won't give you a picture
you can have that instead
and she was like
i just want the picture
then after i gave her the picture she
was like but i'll take your number two
i'm like oh hell no i got up out of here
dude yeah right totally just you you
screwed it all up
um all right um your question
did you ever drunk dial someone you
shouldn't have
drew
oh my god there's like almost not one
red flower in there
um and you would be totally right of
course i've drunk dialed people 100
i mean
let's see who
um i know because like the lizzo was
like the chris evans thing is so cute
she's always like i'm drunk but i love
him and i'm so into their journey um i
hope they end up together um
gosh um
adam sandler it was adam sandler i know
it was adam sandler you know the truth
is like adam is such a safe person for
me it wouldn't matter if i drunk dialed
him he's like one of my dearest friends
i think it was denzel washington it was
denzel washington
i wish i crank called denzel washington
in the middle of the night that's what i
really want to do um okay um well jaleel
i have just loved playing this game with
you
um you are just the best and would you
please come back and do that with me
some more
absolutely okay great and then i'll do
your show and podcast and we can just
keep this party going
yes you do my podcast and you're free to
drop down me anytime
thank you thank you
okay be sure to check out ever after on
topic and on socials as well
[Music]